c'est le passage obligé pour tous les
juges qui sont nommés à la cour suprême
subir un interrogatoire
interminable des sénateurs de ce the box
tous les thèmes sont abordés le droit à
l'avortement le mariage gay la théorie
critique de la race john et son mari ses
enfants et même ses parents sont
présents dans la salle et les sénateurs
républicains ne la ménage pas
les sénateurs tels que vous ai rappelés
à l'ordre
imperturbable kitajima jackson répétait
on lui reproche entre autres d'avoir
rendu des peines trop faible dans les
cas de pornographie infantile prince
claus cus les procureurs réclament et
deux ans pour un homme reconnu coupable
en 2013 vous ne lui avez donné que trois
mois lance le sénateur orly à ce modèle
et un zhanshu en tant que maire et juge
qui a dû regarder ces cas dit-elle vous
êtes loin de la vérité ce sont les
dossiers les plus difficiles narain
could be free rider foundation puis on
lui reproche d'avoir défendu les détenus
de guantanamo alors qu'elle travaillait
pour les services d'aidé juridique
mais
ça m'est égal si les 39 détenus à
guantanamo ne relance le républicain
lindsey graham
of warcraft pourquoi avoir traité
l'ancien secrétaire à la défense dans la
sphère des doges bush de criminel dé
guerre mois de nombreux sénateurs comme
dans nombre d'articles france je ne me
souviens pas de cette référence dit elle
elle a parlé de crime de guerre et non
de criminels de guerre nuance-t-il the
run qui ont rudement cérétans d'accord
avec la théorie critique de la race
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec le
livre qui disent que les bébés sont
racistes d'itunes itunes app engine
aucun enfant ne devrait se faire dire
qu'il est raciste dit elle ou qu'il
n'est pas valorisé price est un peu
importe les caisses des machines cfd est
en et en 1966 dit elle je fais partie de
la première génération a bénéficié du
mouvement des droits civiques et alors
que des gens comme moi est l'occasion de
se présenter à vous aujourd'hui ajoute
elle
pendant vos apps quand le vote final va
arriver conclut le sénateur booker et
que vous allez rejoindre la cour suprême
je vais me réjouir dit il car le pays
sera mieux grâce à des gens comme vous
inébranlable ou les piles au début elle
craque à ce moment là robert cause de
dieu et angie brian jackson devraient
être confirmés d'ici le 8 avril prochain
c'est en tout cas ce que souhaitent les
démocrates mais la composition de la
cour suprême reste inchangée soit six
juges conservateurs et 3 progressiste il
s'est évadé guerguisse radio-canada
washington